Olá,
como vão? Tudo bem? É um prazer estar
aqui com vocês novamente para mais uma
live.
E
boa noite, Eliseu. Boa noite
Cleid Van
Vilma, Alice Vogel, Simone,
Flaviar, parece que é Flaviar, Elizabeth
Baldini,
um grande prazer ter vocês aqui.
Deixa eu Pronto. Ah,
nós temos cerca de 20 perguntas. O
Eliseu já colocou pergunta ao vivo aqui.
Se der tempo a gente a gente responde,
viu? Ô, Eliseu,
bem, vamos apresentar as perguntas aqui.
Quando usar L carnetina ou acetil
carnetina? Pode usar as duas juntas em
quais situações? E usar as duas juntas
mais a cozima que é 10 é recomendado?
É uma boa pergunta essa, né? Bem, é
porque essa adição do acetil é para
aumentar a passagem dacarnitina pela
barreira mata encefálica.
Hum.
Como acetil carnetina é mais caro,
você pode usar elcarnetina quando você
quer potencializar
energia muscular,
recuperação pós- treino,
emagrecimento.
E quando você tá pensando mais em
memória, função cognitiva, foco, atenção
como nootrópico, aí você pode pensar
mais nacarnitina.
E é possível usar as duas juntas, sim.
Por exemplo, você quer assistir o L
carnetina para melhorar o foco em
atenção, em cognição, memória e usar a
elcarnetina sem o acetil para energia do
corpo inteiro, né, paraa atividade
física, por exemplo.
Certo? Agora, se você tá com problema
que predomina o cérebro
e aí você não tá tão preocupado com a
atividade física, você pode tomar sócity
ou carnitina ou se você não tem problema
de foco e atenção, mas tá fraco.
No treino, você pode usar el carnitina.
E é uma ótima ideia associar com com
enzima Q10, PQQ, magnésio de malato,
derribose, creatina,
pode usar alfalipoico.
Bom,
então todas essas combinações são
viáveis.
Minha tia está com câncer. O que que o
doutor acha do protocolo de fembenda
azol e vermectina? Eu tenho muita
esperança quanto esse protocolo, sabe?
Eu tive já alguns casos que responderam
ao protocolo, mas talvez ele não seja
tão maravilhoso quanto tá se pintando
por aí. Então eu queria ter pelo menos
50 casos de pacientes cuidando com essa
esse protocolo para poder responder de
uma maneira mais clara para mim. Eu no
momento eu acho que vale a pena utilizar
sim.
No momento eu acho que vale a pena
utilizar sim.
Os estudos, infelizmente, só são em
vitro ou em vivo,
não tem estudos clínicos,
mas pelo menos o William Max, ele manda
três e-mails por dia falando
da dos supostos efeitos positivos desse
protocolo.
Mas no Brasil eu ia preferir usar o
membendo da Azol no lugar do Fembazol,
tá? Eu acho que não compensa porque o
feminendol é veterinário. Então eu
cheguei à conclusão que é muito parecido
as outras moléculas e não vale a pena
usar o fembendazol no lugar do
membendazol, não.
Então eu preciso de mais dados, mas no
momento a minha visão é positiva sobre
isso. Apesar que eu tive uns pacientes
que o PSA caiu e voltou a subir de novo.
com câncer de próstata.
Doutor, o senhor fez um vídeo no
Instagram com os melhores suplementos
para memória e comparou os mesmos com
maior eficácia
do que os medicamentos para Alzheimer
e comparou os mesmos com maior eficácia
do que os medicamentos. Não, eu não fiz
uma comparação direta não. Não sei se
você entendeu dessa maneira, mas eu não
fiz essa comparação direta.
Lions Main 2000 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Fosfatidina 100 mg. Nicotinamida 600 a
1000 mg. Pqquqoric cararnitina.
Magnestrionato.
Meu esposo tem Alzheimer, porém fui
fazer a fórmula integritária. A Érica
atendente diz que a nicotinamida 600.000
não faria que o correto deveria ser 30.
Não, não é que é o correto ou errado, é
que a dose ela achou alta e ela não quis
te prescrever sem receita.
Quando eu disse que se tratava deoso com
Alzheimer com declínio cognitivo, ela
disse que o senhor tinha orientado
alterar para é porque ela tá confundida
a nicotinamida com niina.
O exanicotinato
é uma opção também, mas ele é um pouco
mais caro, tá? Mas pode usar exctinato,
sim.
Sigo a orientação dela ou a sua. É que a
nicotinamida é difícil dar o o efeito do
flush, né, do vermelhão no rosto com
calor, mas ainda pode dar. E se você não
quer correr risco nenhum de ter o flush,
zero risco de flush, pode usar o
exctinato. Sim,
mudo só essa e sigo com as demais. Pode
mudar, né? Pode mudar.
O geriatra passou me mantina em 10 mgos.
Qual sua opinião? Pode ajudar. Não é um
medicamento que altera a história
natural da doença, mas pode desacelerar
o avanço.
Estamos aguardando abrir sua agenda em
janeiro para sairmos do Nordeste até o
senhor. Obrigado.
Tá bom. Então, houve algum mal
entendido? É possível sim usar
nicotinamida,
tem um risco pequeno, mas existe de
flush. Por isso que ela te falou do
exercinato de noosol.
Tá, mas pode fazer noctinamento.
Qualquer coisa eu converso com ela. Se
você quiser fazer no lugar do
incontinato.
Boa noite, Dra. Alan. O ó de Copaíba já
foi debatido aqui várias vezes, mas
ainda tem algumas dúvidas. Existe algum
estudo que defende o uso em altas doses
dos óleos de Copaíba e Andiroba?
60 e 80 gotas ao 60 e 90 gotas ao dia.
Bem, eu não conheço nenhum estudo. Eu
não achei que associasse o óleo de
copaíba com andoba em altas doses.
O problema com o óleo de copaíba é que
se você utilizar ele em altas doses e
por tempo prolongado, você pode provocar
um efeito chamado efeito colestático nas
vias biliares, ou seja, as vias biliares
ficarem congestionadas.
Isso pode aumentar inclusive os
marcadores
hepáticos, como fosfatase alcalina e o
gama GT.
Então não é recomendado usar copa altas
doses,
então é melhor usar doses normais, tá?
Porque aí tem uma margem de segurança
boa.
Ah, para paciente oncológico, é a dose
segura de tocotrianol do urucum.
e daimarina.
Tem alguns estudos mostrando o uso do
tocotrienol
do urucum para câncer, que ele eh ele
ele acaba ajudando na ação dos
quimioterápicos.
E a dose considerada boa, tocotrenóis, é
até 300 mg por dia.
Tem alguns estudos clínicos, né, que
utilizaram dos mais altas até de 16 mg
de tocotrienois totais, mas eu não
recomendo isso.
Então, tem estudos mostrando que o gama
tocotrienol tem indução de apoptose, ou
seja, morte celular programada.
em várias linhagens de câncer
e ele ajuda também na quimioterapia de
vários
tipos celulares aí.
Então ele é seguro, tá? Uru é seguro,
mas eu não passaria de 300 mg por dia.
Seria o o Naturx lá da
que quem representa o Natomax é a Active
Caldic.
Quanto a Cimarina,
você pode utilizar de 500 mg por dia
nessa faixa aí, tá? no máximo 1 g por
dia.
Mas rarina não é um ativo que é usado
geralmente para câncer, é mais usado
para detox e paraa saúde hepática, tá?
Mas poderia ser um ativo bom para uma
pessoa, por exemplo, fazendo
quimioterapia que tinha
hepatotoxicidade.
Como fica a suplementação D3 magnésio,
Lugol e pacientes renais que fazem
hemodiálise?
Bem,
a vitamina D é um caso especial porque
os pacientes renais crônicos
pode desenvolver hiperparatiroidismo
secundário, tá? É uma situação comum no
renal crônico.
Então, para esses pacientes é melhor
utilizar a fama ativa, que é o
calcetriol, tá? Tem hoje na farmácia
comum o calcitriol
paraa venda, tá? em vez de usar a
vitamina D3, que é o cólicalciferol,
e tem que monitorar de maneira rigorosa
o cálcio, o fósforo, tá?
e usar com e com magnésio, que é
obrigatório.
Paciente também que tá fazendo diálise
pode ter retenção de magnésio no
organismo, então tem que tá medindo o
magnésio no sangue antes de fazer a
suplementação.
E o iodo, por exemplo, poderia estar
utilizando sim o logol.
Certo? Então não sai dando magnésio de
qualquer jeito, nem vitamina D. Vitamina
D tem que ser o calcitrireol,
tem que dar o magnésio, tem que dar
junto K2 e aí você pode dar o Lugol,
sim, não tem restrição, tá bom?
Muito cuidado com o paciente dialítico.
Muito cuidado.
Boa noite. A carne vermelha faz mal para
quem tem a doce de Parkson,
tá? Eh, geralmente quem tem Paxon não
pode comer muita carne vermelha, porque
a carne vermelha libera uma substância
chamado emina no organismo, que em
pessoas saudáveis geralmente é bem
eliminada, mas em potadores de Paxon
pode acelerar degeneração neuronal.
O Dr. Cícero Galimbra fez um trabalho
que ele demonstrou que pacientes que
eliminaram a carne vermelha e fizeram a
reposição de B12 tiveram a estabilização
e do Parkson e também alguns casos
tiveram regressão.
E esse problema é maior para carnes
processadas.
Então, para quem tem Paxon, é bom sim
restringir carne vermelha, optar pela
dieta mais mediterrânea e comer carne
branca, tá? Especialmente peixes gordos,
ricos em ômega-3, nozes leguminosas, tá?
Frango,
beleza? Então, sim, faz todo sentido que
você tá falando, tá?
No caso do Paxon, faz sentido
eh reduzir bastante a carne vermelha.
Com relação à moda ultimamente das
banheiras de gelo para inflamação,
ouvi algo sobre o risco de danos renais
por conta de diminuição da circulação
que ocorre.
Hum. Então, pode acontecer uma
vasoconstrição, ou seja, contração dos
vasos induzindo
induzido pelo frio.
Isso geralmente vai reduzir mais é o
fluxo sanguíneo periférico,
só que teoricamente poderia também
comprometer a irrigação ou perfusão
renal.
Porém, eu não, eu não lembro de ter
visto nenhum trabalho falando isso. Isó,
só um risco teórico.
Agora, se for uma pessoa que já tem
problema renal ou tem estreitamento de
artéria renal, que tem hipertensão
renovascular,
eu realmente eu evitaria as banheiras
geladas, tá?
Agora pro cidadão normal, eu acho que
esse risco deve ser muito baixo.
E a banheira não pode ser diária, tá?
A banheira de gelo não pode ser diária,
ela tem que ser uma coisa esporádica.
No máximo duas vezes por semana. Essa
banheira gelada aí.
Olá, Dra. Alan. Poderei, por gentileza,
falar sobre desidrose nos pés.
Recentemente tive algumas bolhas muito
pequenas do meu pé. Em consulta com
dermatologista, ela disse que é
desidrose, prescreveu uma pomada com
corticovide. Eu gostaria de orientação
sobre forma de tratamento e prevenção
que não seja com corticovide,
tá? A desidrose é uma forma de
inflamação na pele localizada, tá ligado
à deficiência nutricional,
a disbiose cutânea, né, ou seja,
desequilíbrio das bactérias da pele,
reação a alimentos pró-inflamatórios.
Então, o que que orientaria? Primeiro,
melhorar a alimentação, fazer uma
alimentação não inflamatória,
tirar glúten, leite derivados,
processados, industrializados,
refinados, essas coisas se conhecem
muito bem.
E aí você faz com pressas frias de chá
de camomila ou banhos de água com sal
amargo, sal deon né, que é o magnésio na
forma de cloreto.
Então faz essas compressas
por 15 a 20 minutos, duas a três vezes
ao dia.
OK?
Hidratação da pele com óleo de coco,
pode ser óleo de jojoba.
Pode usar óleos essenciais de meluca e
de cravo. Tem propriedades
anti-inflamatórias. Só pode diluir umas
duas, três gotinhas de meluca ou cravo
no óleo de coco e passar na pele.
Evitar sapatos fechados durante as
crises. Manter a região bem seca.
Suplementação adequada, né? Ômega-3,
magnésio, vitamina D,
zinco selênio.
Pode utilizar um probiótico também para
pele, né? Para disbiose cutânea.
Seria isso.
Dr. Victor Sorrentino fez uma live
desmascarando o último estudo sobre
melatonina. E sobre esse mesmo estudo,
você fez um vídeo sobre melatonina
concordando. É, eu não concordei 100%,
não sei se você viu o vídeo direito.
E diminuição das doses. Eu concordei que
é prudente diminuir as doses, tá? Foi
isso que eu falei no vídeo. Eu não falei
que era veneno, melatonina, que vocês
gostam de fazer as coisas tudo radical,
né?
É que vocês olham o título, né? E aí
vocês não não assistem o vídeo inteiro.
O problema é o seguinte, a gente tem que
fazer vídeo com título chamativo, senão
o YouTube não entrega e a pessoa tem que
assistir o vídeo inteiro, senão ela fica
com dúvida, tá?
Assiste o vídeo de novo que você vai
entender, tá? Porque eu acho que você
não viu direito esse vídeo.
O fato é que eu já escuto isso há muito
tempo, tá? Eh, na questão da melatonina,
eh, ela tem um lado negativo, sim. Ela
pode, em altas doses causar
vasoconstrição em indivíduos que são
predispostos.
E como qualquer outra substância,
melatonina, você não pode sair
aumentando de qualquer jeito. Eu, na
minha prática diária, eu não tenho
problemas com melatonina.
Eu geralmente já usei até doses altas
para câncer. Eu falo isso no vídeo, que
para câncer tem justificativa de usar
dose altas.
Uso errado é que o vilão, tá? Não é a
questão de demonizar, é que vocês acham
que tudo é 880, entendeu? Que ou é bom
ou é ruim, entendeu? Esse é o problema
da polarização hoje em dia, né? As
pessoas não têm mais senso crítico de
nada.
Pessoas que têm pressão arterial
descontrolada, pessoas que têm arritmia
ou que usam um vaso dilatador, tem que
prestar mais atenção na melatonina, ok?
É esse que é o ponto.
Assiste o vídeo de novo, tá? Com
carinho, com cuidado,
em vez de só ler o título do vídeo.
Demo como carreador, se for ingerido,
ele pode carregar quais suplementos?
Pergunto pro Keli que ele pode carregar
tudo.
Ele geralmente é um é quase que um
solvente universal, tá?
Ele tem uma capacidade extraordinária de
penetrar nas membranas e atuar como
carreador. Então, teoricamente, ele
transporta quase tudo mesmo pra pele.
Ele aumenta a absorção pela pele e de
praticamente tudo que se você utilizar.
Minerais, vitaminas, aminoácidos,
moléculas liposolúves em geral.
Então essa característica ele tem de ser
um excelente carreador também é uma faca
de dois gumes, porque ele pode arrastar
consigo outras substâncias que podem ser
maléficas, né? Então tem que tomar
cuidado com isso.
Se você for utilizar DMSO oral, tem que
tomar um certo cuidado, porque às vezes
ele pode aumentar a absorção de algumas
toxinas que você possa estar tendo
contato pelo trato gastrointestinal,
certo?
Boa noite. Gostaria de saber como tomar
azul de metil no PA
30. Põe na boca e engole, né? Assim que
a gente toma. Tô brincando. Eh, geral, é
só você mandar fazer em cápsula, não
fica fazendo em gota não, que vocês se
confundem com a dose. Sem jejum ou após
uma refeição. Tanto faz. Isso não faz
diferença, não. Mandei aviar uma receita
antiga que me fez
uma médica há mais de 2 anos e na
ocasião não conheceu seus benefícios e
acho que nem fiz uso. Ela apenas
prescreveu
tomar uma cápsula uma vez ao dia até
completar a quantidade prescrita. É, se
ela não especificou porque não precisava
se preocupar com isso. Posso usar como
uso contínuo. Eu uso continuamente já há
muito tempo. Considera
em detalhes
esse esse conteúdo, porque por Deus não
consigo acompanhar tantas informações no
WhatsApp.
Apesar de a ideia do grupo do WhatsApp é
vocês trocarem ideia, gente, tá? Não é
de eu responder nada lá, não, tá? Então
fique tranquila. Se você colocar as
perguntas no formulário, eu vou
responder as lives.
Apesar de ter formação acadêmica
superior, sou semianalfabeta virtual. Eu
também tenho problema em acompanhar
grupo no WhatsApp. Eu tenho uma
dificuldade de seguir grupos. Eu me
irrito facilmente com a quantidade de
mensagens e me desinteresso também. Eu
tenho esse problema,
tá? Então fica sossegado, toma 100 mg em
cápsula, toma em qualquer hora, não tem
nenhum tipo de problema. Sei se é jejum,
sem jejum
e eu uso já vários anos, então eu posso
te dizer que é é bem tranquilo para uso
contínuo. É bem seguro.
Ah, óbvio, se você for jovem, Vilma, eu
não sei sua idade, e você engravidar, aí
eu pararia na gravidez, tá? na gestação
você não mantenha.
Vamos paraa próxima pergunta aqui.
Vixe Maria, tem uma pergunta enorme. Dr.
Eu propus no grupo que você fizesse uma
enquete de uma live fechada em qualquer
plataforma, caso na comunidade não seja
possível falar sobre isso, que seria uma
atualização da live do Rumble ou Vimio
que você fez anos atrás, pois acredito
que muitas coisas aconteceram, novas
descobertas, teorias da conspiração,
tá? Você não falou de que assunto você
tá falando, mas parece que é a
picadinha, né?
que hoje se provaram verdadeiras na sua
visão. E se as doenças provocadas pela
picada por serem provocadas por uma
substância externa não natural por terem
spike diferente quando provocadas por
mal alimentação. Gente, coloca ponto,
coloca
vírgula nas coisas.
Ah, quando se vocês tem dificuldade de
pôr ponto, vírgula, põe lá no XGPT e
pede para arrumar o texto. Fica ruim de
ler assim.
quando provocados por má alimentação,
por exemplo, problemas cardíacos
resultantes de má alimentação
e mais leve o tratamento do que os
provocados pela Spike, ou se Spike fica
sempre provocando a mesma doença.
E se os rumores de centenas de milhares
de mortes por cardíacos podem ser
verdade, atualizações do mundo todo, já
que o Brasil é atrasado.
Nesse ponto eu não acho que o Brasil
esteja atrasado, não.
Por favor, doutor, faça enquete. Se o
pessoal aceitar, você faz. Se não, então
não. Mas eu acho que é necessário, é
muito pertinente. É, eu não vou fazer
isso no YouTube, nem com a vacauça,
porque senão eu posso perder até o
canal, tá?
Olha, gente, e quem fala muito de prote
spike, que tá muito ligada nesse
assunto, é a Juliana Varão, tá?
Deixa eu pensar aqui. Eu conversei com a
Juliana Varão lá em Portugal. Eu não
conhecia ela pessoalmente.
Até conheci. Eu acho que ela foi num
evento que eu fui também há uns anos
atrás, mas eu não cheguei a falar com
ela direito.
Pensar se se ela tá interessada em fazer
uma live para vocês aí. Mas aí eu teria
que fazer como se fosse um webinário,
não daria para fazer no YouTube, não,
tá? Vou pensar no assunto,
gente. Mas assim, essencialmente não
mudou muita coisa. Eu já falei muito
sobre esse assunto das medidas de
proteção contra a Spike. Isso porque eu
saiba não mudou. Agora sim, apareceram
outros estudos, apareceram outras
evidências, mas assim, essencialmente a
prevenção
ela não mudou não, tá? Que eu saiba, tá
bom?
Mas eu vou pensar no assunto, tá?
Dosagem ideal para suplementar co enzima
Q10. Geralmente é entre 200 e 400 mg por
dia, tá bom?
Se você tiver fazendo um só prevenção,
pode usar 100 mg por dia. Então fica
nessa
faixa de 100 a 400. Tem gente que usa
dos mais altas, mas é um ativo meio
caro, então pode pesar no bolso, tá?
Sempre ingiria co enzima Q1 com
refeições com gordura porque é
liposolúvel.
Pode ser óleo de coco, omega-3, abacate,
oliaas.
Prefira a forma biquinol, se você puder
em detrimento da biquinona.
Vamos pra próxima.
Dosagem ideal de citrato de potássio,
citrático de magnésio e magnésio
queelado para cálculos. Aí você não usa
o queelado nesse caso, não, tá? Ah,
geralmente nesse caso,
que que eu faço?
Eu
dou o citrato de potássio
eh na faixa de 500 mg
no sachê mais 500 mg de cloreto de
magnésio ou citrato de magnésio,
tá? É assim que eu faço e passo, peço
pra pessoa tomar dois ou três sachês por
dia.
Aí o magnésio esquelado aqui não não
entraria não, não faria muito sentido,
tá? Não sei que você teria outra
indicação para usar o magnésio queelado,
tá? Então, de novo,
existe o litocite. Se você quiser
comprar na farmácia, o litocite
é o citrato de potássio. E aí você pode
mandar fazer só o citrato de magnésio ou
manda fazer os dois juntos em sachê, tá?
500 mg de citrato de potássio, 500 mg de
citrato de magnésio, considerando esses
500 mg,
que é a parte do mineral, tá? O peso do
mineral, não da molécula inteira, OK?
equivalente ao alimentar que eu tô
falando aqui.
Tem que ingerir 2 L e meio de água por
dia, manter o pH urinário entre 6 e 7,
se for possível comprar aquelas fitinhas
que mede pH urinário,
cortar os alimentos processados,
industrializados, que é muito importante
para reduzir o o xarope de milho rico em
frutose que aumenta o ácido úrico, tá
bom?
Na dieta carnívora, a pessoa consome,
consegue, né, hipertrofiar e ficar em
cetose ao mesmo tempo. Não, não é
possível hipertrofia durante cetose, tá?
Aí você vai ter o período do dia que
você vai ficar em cetose e o período do
dia que você precisa sair da cetose para
poder conseguir ter aumento de massa
muscular, tá? Então, eh, é possível no
mesmo dia você tá em cetose, no horário
e no outro horário você não tá em
cetose, mas durante cetose você não vai
conseguir ganhar massa muscular.
Exatos muito assim
que chocam um com o outro, né?
Existe vários aminoácidos que são
glicogênicos, né, que
passam pro neoglicênese
e viram glicose. Então, se você comer
muita proteína, eh, você vai ter muita
dificuldade de entrar em cetose.
Agora existe uma possibilidade, tá? Se
você tiver fazendo atividade física
e comendo muita proteína, dependendo da
sua massa muscular e da sua,
seu nível de atividade física, até
possível durante atividade física você
entrar em cetose,
tá? Mesmo comendo muita proteína, mas aí
a tendência que depois que você para a
atividade física, a cetose vai parar se
você continuar comendo muita proteína.
Então assim, pode ser possível assim
fazer hipertrofia,
mas não vai ser num momento que você tá
fazendo cetosea, tá? Não é exatamente
nesse momento.
Panelas e frigideiras com revestimento
em dióxito de titânio são tóxicas como
teflon.
Bem, existe uma diferença entre o
dióxido de titânio
revestimento e o dióxido de titânio
aditivo, tá?
Supostamente, no caso das panelas, o
titânio ele forma uma camada não
reativa,
ele não chega
a ser desgastado com a
limpeza, né, com a lavagem.
Então é diferente do teflon.
Então as panelas de tâio são mais
seguras nesse ponto, tá?
Então você tem que ficar preocupado com
dióxido de titân em produtos de higiene
pessoal e também em produtos que você
vai ingerir.
Você pode estar utilizando então as
panelas com titâio como revestimento,
cerâmica ou vidro, OK? Ou cobre também,
pode ser aço cirúrgico também, tá bom?
Nesse ponto tá tranquilo.
Por uma pessoa que tem alimentação
saudável, bons de vida, apesar de ter
parado de fumar há 20 anos, permanece
por um período de mais de um mês com a
condição de encatarramenta após gripe,
sem qualquer outro sintoma.
faz sempre uso de fluidificantes,
naquitoprópolis,
nebolização com soro, ederx, própolis,
chaopes, mel, alho, etc.
E mesmo assim o encatarramento perdura
por muitos tempo.
Tem pessoas que têm inflamação residual
nas vias aéreas. Pode ser bronquasia,
por exemplo,
ah, que ficou residual de uma infecção
do passado, tá?
Então pode ser um bronquasia que não
curou,
que é uma inflamação residual.
Então sim, provavelmente essa pessoa
estaria pior se não tivesse utilizando
esses agentes que você falou aí.
Então tem que fazer uma avaliação, a
tomografia de tórax para ver se não tem
bronquasia.
Checar alimentação, se não tá tendo
componentes inflamatórios,
utilizar antiinflamatórios naturais como
curcumina, bosia, serrata, ômega3,
peia, né, o palmitonitan lamina, que eu
já falei em várias lives anteriores,
quercetina, vitamina C.
Então, faz uma avaliação adequada aí com
um epidemologista
para fazer uma prova de
função pulmonar, né, uma espirometria
e provavelmente uma tomografia de tórax.
Qual a sua avaliação sobre o suplemento
alimentar de nome curflan
2? Tem palmito etanolamina que eu adoro,
pé activo, acabei de falar disso agora.
Curcumina, colágeno dois, vitamina
complexo B. Esse produto específico eu
não conheço, mas me parece uma
combinação muito boa, tá?
Teria ação sim, ótimo, antiinflamatória,
analgésica,
a reduz a dor. OK.
É uma ótima combinação, apesar de não
conhecer esse produto aí.
Então, me pareceu muito interessante.
É uma combinação que tem respaldo
científico muito sólido.
Agora tem que ver quando grau 4 pode ser
que não tem uma resposta total, tá? E
risartros se for avançada, a mesma
coisa.
Nesse caso vai ter que ver mais coisas
junto. Talvez fazer ozônio, fazer
plasma rico em plaquetas,
ácido hialurônico,
certo?
Mas vale a pena sim fazer esses agentes.
Em caso de câncer de mama, não hormônio
dependente, protocolo de própolis verde,
mas imectina pode ser útil? Pode.
Amectina não sobrecarrega o fígado, já
tão exigido. Não, essa história de que
ivmectina ataca o fígado, isso tá mais
do que comprovado na prática. Eu cansei
de usar vimectina em dose alta aqui em
paciente e não vi nada acontecer no
fígado, tá? Isso é uma conversa fiada.
Isso é uma das maiores mentiras que
foram faladas durante a pandemia, tá? Eu
posso te comprovar na prática que isso
não acontece,
tá? Não acontece.
Então assim, aectina, o problema que eu
tenho visto dela é distorção visual, tá?
que assusta os pacientes e o pessoal
fica com a visão assim com os com os os
pontos luminosos, mas não tô vendo
degradação da visão, ninguém ficando com
comprometimento de visão, mas os pontos
luminosos t assustado, tá? Mas
geralmente é temporário
e não vejo problema no fígado, tá?
Nunca vi nenhum paciente subir enzima
hepática por causa da evimectina. Eu
tinha esse medo quando eu comecei a
usar, mas perdi esse medo depois de usar
em algumas dezenas de pacientes.
Hoje eu tenho convicção que não acontece
isso.
Ah, pera aí, deixa eu ver aqui as outras
perguntas que eu não respondi.
Dout. Alan, por que que na live você
então falou sobre perigo de telas mais
pornografia, causar sintomas parecidos
com autismo? Em casos extremos,
você então falou por você não citou, não
é tão relevante assim, não. Na pesquisa
que eu fiz, não é relevante essa sua
preocupação não de que vai criar
autismo, tá? A fórmula que você citou
tem que ser associada
ao abandono das telas. Sim, o abandono
da tela é o principal, tá?
Abandono da tela principal.
pornografia por uns 3s meses. Uso apenas
de WhatsApp. Não, se você tá usando o
WhatsApp, você tá usando tela, né?
Se a pessoa conseguir controlar, né?
Ah, três vezes ao dia na continuidade do
problema, usando a fórmula proposta por
você
ou só a fórmula por Tá confusa essa
pergunta, né?
Olha,
eu não achei nada que fazendo referência
a pornografia e sintomas de autista, tá?
Não sei onde você viu isso, mas eu não
achei.
O resto das suas perguntas tá um pouco
confuso de responder, mas assim, a ficar
longe da tela é muito mais importante do
que tomar o suplemento, tá bom?
Gente, eh,
por que que tá com pergunta de novo de
galinheiro aqui?
fazer o seguinte, eu vou eu vou jogar a
resposta dessa pergunta do garinheiro no
grupo, tá bom? Eu vou pular essa aqui.
A fórmula da super live de domingo tem
contraindicação. A integritar passa 120
cápsulas e o ideal para neuroplastidade,
em casos estaremos de uso
de tela e pornografia.
Não, não tem contraindicação. É só por
causa da do vencimento da fórmula, tá?
Só por causa do vencimento.
Deixa eu ver se tem mais alguma
pergunta. Tem. Dout. Alan, minha mãe vai
se consultar com você pela telemedicina,
fica do mesmo jeito sendo presencial.
Ela mostrando os exames. A diferença é
que a gente não consegue fazer exame
físico, tá? Mas fora isso é bem parecida
a consulta, tá? Dá para ver os exames em
tempo real, sem problema nenhum. É só
vocês terem organização e tá com uma
internet boa.
Ã, e mostrando transvaginal, por
exemplo.
Não, o laudo do do transvaginal é a
mesma coisa, é só mandar o PDF com exame
que a gente consegue ver tudo, tá? A
diferença, como expliquei, é não ter o
exame físico.
Depois eu e meu pai também vamos nos
consultar confiando em Deus. Deus te
abençoe.
Você que seja abençoado, viu?
Bem, pessoal, eu vou jogar a resposta do
da pergunta do garinheiro aqui na no
grupo, tá?
Vamos ver as perguntas ao vivo aqui.
Hoje dá para responder umas perguntas ao
vivo.
A carne vermelha possui creatina. Quem
faz dieta carnívora e musculação precisa
tomar suplemento creatina? Precisa,
porque a quantidade de creatina que tem
na carne não é tão grande assim. Você
teria que comer uma quantidade absurda
de carne para poder ter a creatina
necessária, tá?
Então assim, para fins de ganho de massa
muscular, eh, tem que suplementar sim,
se o objetivo for otimizar o ganho de
massa muscular e também a energia pro
treino.
A razão que eu não concordo, não é que
eu não concordo, pessoa quer fazer, faz,
tá? Eh, é porque mexe muito no cortisol
da pessoa, tá? A razão principal é essa.
Então, a pessoa pode ter um
desequilíbrio do cortisol por ficar
tempo demais de jejum. Eu falei isso na
no vídeo que eu gravei sobre isso. É só
rever o vídeo.
E isso que você falou também é um fator,
tá? Esse que você falou aí do dos
nutrientes que de detox, tá? Mas é um
fator menor.
Isso é uma pergunta muito boa, Eliseu.
Tá. Eh, o que acontece é o seguinte, tá?
Existe uma linha de pensamento que acha
que não é necessário fibra para ter boa
saúde intestinal. E de maneira indireta,
eu vi esse estudo recente, que eu até
dividi com quem tava na live do nível
dois domingo passado,
que existe evidências de que não é só
fibra, que é um carboidrato que ajuda no
microbioma, mas as proteínas podem
também ser eh um bom agente para
microbioma intestinal, tá?
Então tem pessoas aí que
defendem a ideia de que não é necessário
fibra convencional de carboidrato para
ter um bom microbioma intestinal. Eu
acho que esse pessoal no fundo tem
razão,
tá? E se a pessoa bebe água o suficiente
e come f e come víceras, come músculo,
tá? Eh, não é todo mundo que vai ficar
constipado, não. Existe uma compensação
do intestino. E e outra coisa também,
não é necessário ficar estritamente
carnívoro. Você pode comer basicamente
carnívoro e acrescentar vegetais que
crescem acima do solo, folhas, verduras
junto com a carne e com as víceras, tá?
Então eu acho que hoje em dia tem pouco
motivo para você não comer algum tipo de
vegetal junto com as carnes e as
víceras. Eu acho que no geral faz
sentido sim.
Boa noite a todos que eu não dei boa
noite ainda. Cleidan Vilma, acho que
acho que eu já dei para Cle Van e Vilma.
Alice Vogel, o Simone,
ã, Elizabe, Regiane,
Maria Helena
faz um vídeo sobre Dribose, tem pouca
coisa sobre suplemento. Boa, boa, boa
dica a sua, Antônio. Boa dica.
Qual que é o valor da teleconsulta? Eu
prefiro não falar valores aqui, tá,
Antônio, tá? A razão de eu não falar
valores é que pode ter reajuste e fica
gravado em vídeo e alguém pode no futuro
pegar esse vídeo e falar: "Olha, tá
registrado aqui o valor". Ele falou que
era outro valor e levar no Procons. Sei
lá. Tem, parece maluquice, mas existe
isso, tá?
Então eu prefiro não registrar em vídeo
o valor. Isso é conversa com a
secretária.
A minha pergunta sobre azul de metil.
Respondi sim, Vilma.
Respondi sim.
Não foi a tua pergunta que fala de 30 mg
e que se podia tomar em jejum ou não?
Respondi. Não foi essa a pergunta. Deixa
eu ver aqui. Vamos lá.
Deixa eu voltar aqui.
Você não tava prestando atenção, eu
acho.
Vamos voltar aqui. Vamos ver. Eu acho
que foi uma das primeiras perguntas essa
do azul de metileno.
Deixa eu ver se é o seu nome que tá lá,
porque talvez
tem 24.
Esse esse coiso aqui ele atualiza em
tempo real, tá? Se se aparece pergunta.
Deixa eu ver se acho que eu pulei.
Nossa, que dor de copaíba.
Ué,
cadê a pergunta do do azul?
Mas eu respondi sim.
Quem tá acompanhando aí ao vivo,
por favor, me diz, ó. Aqui, ó, se vai
ser aqui, ó. Vilma Camagos. Eu respondi
sim. Ó, você dormiu na hora que eu
respondi.
Pode tomar em jejum, pode tomar com
alimento, faz diferença nenhuma, tá?
Você é que não não escutou.
Bem, pessoal,
muito obrigado pela presença de vocês.
Vilma, você está escutando agora? Você
entendeu o que eu falei? Vou esperar um
minuto aí por causa do delay.
Tá bom, você não ouviu. Eh, tudo bem. É
porque também a tua pergunta eu respondi
relativamente rápido.
Assiste o vídeo gravado que você vai ver
lá. E vai ter o documento também, né?
Vai vai constar no documento isso daí
tanto no
na marcação de tempo no vídeo, quanto
vai constar no documento. Beleza?
Bem pessoal, um beijo para vocês no
coração.
Até a próxima. Tchau tchau. Obrigada,
Alice. Obrigada. Eu preciso dormir bem
hoje porque eu tô cansadão hoje. Até a
próxima.